this might be a fun question to ask
to kind of explore the idea of the
expanding universe
yeah so the the radius of the observable
universe is
45.7 billion light years
yeah and the age of the universe is
13.7 yeah billion years
that's less right than the radius of the
universe
yeah how's that possible so that's a
great question
so that and i meant to bring a little a
little prop i have with
ping pong balls on a rubber hose a
rubber band i use it in many of the
lectures that one can find of me online
but you have in an expanding universe
the space itself
between galaxies or more correctly
clusters of galaxies
expanding so imagine light going
from one cluster to another it traverses
some distance
and then while it's traversing the rest
that part that it already traveled
through
continues to expand now 13.7 billion
years might have gone by
since the light that we are saying
seeing from
the early stages the so-called cosmic
microwave background radiation which is
the
the afterglow of the big bang or the
echo of the big bang
yeah 13.7 billion years have gone by
that's how long it's taken that light to
reach us but while it's been traveling
that distance
the parts that it already traveled
continue to expand so it's like you're
walking
on at an airport you know on one of
these walkways
and you're walking along because you're
trying to get to your terminal
but the walkway is continuing as well
you end up traveling a greater distance
or the same distance faster is another
way of
putting it right that's why you get on
one of these traveling walkways
so you get a roughly roughly a factor of
pi
you know but it's more like 3.2 i think
but when you work it all out
you multiply the number of years the
universe has been in existence
by you know three and a quarter or so
and that's how you get
this 46 billion light year radius
but how is that let me ask some
nice dumb questions uh how is that not
traveling faster than the speed of light
yeah it's not traveling faster than the
speed of light because locally
at any point if you were to measure the
light the photon
zipping past it would not be exceeding
the speed of light
the speed of light is a locally measured
quantity
after light has traversed some distance
if the rubber band keeps on stretching
then yes it looks like the light
traveled a greater distance
than it would have had the space not
been expanding
but locally it never was exceeding the
speed of light it's just that the
distance through which it already
traveled
then went off and expanded on its own
some more
and if you give the light credit
so to speak for having traversed that
distance well then it looks like
it's going faster than the speed of
light but that's not it's not that's not
what happens
right that's not how speed works speed
and in relativity
also the other thing um that is
interesting is that
you know if you take two ping-pong balls
that are sufficiently far apart
especially in an accelerating universe
you can easily have them moving apart
from one another
faster than the speed of light so you
know take two ping-pong balls that were
originally
four hundred thousand kilometers from
each other and let
every centimeter in your rubber band
expand to two
in one second then suddenly this 400
000 kilometer distance is 800 000
kilometers
it went out by 400 000 kilometers in one
second
that exceeds the 300 000 kilometer per
speed of light but that light limit that
that particle limit
in special relativity applies to objects
moving
through a pre-existing space there's
nothing in either special or general
relativity that prevents space itself
from expanding faster than the speed of
light that's no problem einstein
wouldn't have had a problem with
with uh within it with a universe as
observed now by cosmologists
yeah i um i'm not sure i'm yet ready to
deal emotionally with
expanding space like that to me is one
of the most
awe-inspiring things you know starting
from the big bang
it's definitely abstract it's space
itself is expanding
you